yeah my looking at a camera this one
what up my name is Josh kavita's I'm
here today to paint the off-white Jordan
one that's re gonna go yeah these are
tight I grew up like hella broke you
know my parents are immigrants from
Guatemala so buying expensive sneaked
sneakers it's like the [ __ ] are you
talking about you know I think a lot of
it has to do with my older brother and
my dad dad was you know half of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] in her house he made my
brothers architect now in LA I hated him
dude he was so good at [ __ ] drawing
like elementary school like art show
this was like drawing my mom like
perfect face you know and like everyone
else is like chicken scratch when I'm
done with these these are gonna look
like a drawing you know and like that's
that's like what I'm super into right
now partnered up with Jordan for
all-star weekend the Jordan one just
regular kind of like had gone somewhat
viral I guess and my buddy Frank works
over there so Frank hit me up and he's
like I'm gonna be in town for this like
Jordan party he wears a obviously like
Frank hook like wearing it at an event
like wasn't a bad look some of the
higher-ups are kind of like oh you know
that guy let's get involved we obviously
wants you to be there
painting sneakers during our activation
in Little Tokyo but also we would like
some artwork to showcase like inside the
space I want you to do metal backboards
East Coast styles with different designs
of the holes and I'm like alright cool
that was the first project with Jordan
the fact that Nike flash Jordan allowed
Virgil to do this to shoes changes
everything moving forward I've heard so
many times from other people that have
done collaborations that like there's no
way this was possible when they tried
you know the Astrid they're like no
you're [ __ ] tripping you know so the
fact they let him do this [ __ ] like look
at this woosh [ __ ] Wow the second
they came out the red and white so I was
like dude they got to make a [ __ ]
white pair and if they do like I got to
do this [ __ ]
the concept is bringing sketches to life
a lot of people like call it cartooning
which like I think some stupid Tinker
Hatfield is like a legend in the sneaker
game then he was so interested in like
what I was doing he's like what like
like this is crazy he's like I love this
picking and choosing the lines you're
paying homage to like you know designers
which like rarely get credit usually
just like goes to production and people
just see like the final product and
people kind of forget about like where
it actually started he's like you're
bringing light to that that day was was
kind of wild I'm like literally like 10
minutes later like Russell Westbrook
walks up and he's like oh you're the guy
doing the sneaker is that gonna crap I'm
like yeah what's good you know you know
how to get a pair of like to be 100%
honest like I get a shitload of DM snow
and it's just like how do I get these
shoes obviously like almost every day it
was just like DM what up we like what
you're doing I worked with LeBron but he
spent LeBron and I was like I mean we'll
see you know I kind of just like tested
it out and I'm like word this is how
much it is
guys like you know usually we don't pay
for this like you're gonna get exposure
I didn't know if it was real or not so I
was like kind of home sales being an
[ __ ] but I was like you know to be
honest like I don't need exposure right
now like I need funds it kind of just
like one goes for like a few weeks and I
was like all right like that that wasn't
real you know a few weeks later hit me
back again he's they go like let's do it
we want you to do his off Wyatt
Air Force One how's it go send him here
sent him over I painted them it was one
of those where it's like I wasn't sure
obviously you never know what one is he
gonna wear them and two is he gonna be
like y'all like I just got these right
so I kind of just went ahead and went on
my Instagram and I was like [ __ ] it
these are like 101 for LeBron two days
later after I post that photo
the Cavs posted it it was kind of
surreal to be honest he's a [ __ ] icon
so after that so-and-so football player
baseball player I don't wanna like drop
names
we're like y'all I need a pair now this
exact I do a legal [ __ ] too
you know I think of like Banksy and like
all the dudes from seventh letter at the
end of the day I think the majority of
what I do is like street art no one pays
attention to cones
you don't say like it's just a [ __ ]
thing that's always there I wanted
something that was somewhat easily
accessible obviously like a decent size
not too big and from the jump I wanted
to be able to leave you know pieces of
what I do around the world and I've
dropped them everywhere from LA
obviously in New York Chicago London I
just [ __ ] them up whatever
there's a small smear right here you see
that that just [ __ ] up this is like
you know I'm like oh [ __ ] obviously like
artists that work with like paint and
like other colors if there's an error or
something they can kind of blend I'm
working with [ __ ] black and white so
if I [ __ ] up a line you know to me the
whole thing's [ __ ] lace this thing up
[Music]